foreign
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
so this video was sent to me from a
brother and this is Asda so we go
shopping we Asda Tesco little Audi
whatever it may be and this is a footage
of people doing food so you have no idea
but these footages we should know what
you're about to watch is showing women
especially Elder women for some reason
they like to be witches yeah they are
doing some sort of a spell or something
on the meat that you me and you consume
let's watch this video and come back and
see how we can protect ourselves the
enemy is so blatant with his devices
that at this point there's daylight
witchcraft happening they don't even
have to conform to Darkness anymore they
don't even have to come out and creep
out in the night because we're so
desensitive to Witchcraft witches are
actually going into supermarkets in
broad daylight and putting curses on
food look at this right now
one prayer from a Christian and you're
getting arrested you give out a Bible
they will actually arrest you but see a
witch come into a shop and start cursing
the Breads and putting it on the honey
like this person is literally putting a
cast on bread and honey and regular
everyday items in ASDA like
and it's just nothing and people are
just walking around I don't even know if
the person was reported we actually need
to be interceding and praying over our
food no we don't live in fear no we're
not intimidated no we're not scared of
people who are going around putting
sickness and Witchcraft and whatever
nonsense over food but what we need to
do is follow the word which tells us to
pray over our food and also to just
declare the blood of Jesus as well so
guys you saw that for yourself
subhanallah just think of it and this is
a Christian woman given raising
awareness about that and talking about
you know to her beliefs that you have
the lord's name which is Jesus which
will say I would be like literally you
know that's not going to protect you you
know doing shirk you know associating
partners of God Almighty which is
because the biggest sins Satan's going
to be happy I mean that's worse than
this individual probably doing uh okay
you are claiming that Jesus is God but
off topic coming back so brothers and
sisters I I advise every single one of
you guys to download the app which I
have which is the app you need to do
this in the morning and evening besides
doing your fart which is Salah
fasting all this kind of stuff you need
to understand and I've mentioned this so
many times there is a reality outside of
what we can see and observe with our
five senses yeah touch smell see taste
and here yeah and feel yeah these are
five senses there is a reality that
exists outside of that a lot of us are
oblivious to that we genuinely act as if
it doesn't exist that's why we don't
take precautions and this comes in many
forms evil eye magic the prophet
salallah narration pointed to the graves
and said do you know how many people are
in there because of evil eye this is haq
evil eye is Hawk it is real so many
people neglect their care and imagine
you're going shopping and buying the
meat that someone's done set on and you
have no damn idea do you see why it's so
important that we physically protect
ourselves and if our life's in danger we
have CCTV cameras security cards we do
everything in our power why because it's
a physical danger we See Without Eyes
the Unseen World is more dangerous than
a physical world brothers and sisters
yes of course you can die but the point
is this is something that attacks the
soul so brother and sisters do you have
cat in the morning and the evening it is
not damn hard and if you don't you will
see the consequences of it this video is
inevident the evidence to show that evil
people exist and you should take
precautions like one of them
that you do is one that we recite we say
yeah
oh every living one all Eternal one by
your mercy I call on you to set right
all my Affairs do not Place me in charge
of my soul even for the blinking of an
eye guys we do this to our why because I
us ourselves are a fitness to ourselves
our nephs that's why we ask Allah to not
even leave us to ourself for the
blinking of an eye we need Allah's help
and Aid every single second so please
guys download the healthcare app do it
in the morning and the evening and you
will see your life change because I
never used to do it and I got hit really
bad I'm not going to say it was
but I felt it I know what I went through
I do not miss my I've had up from that
day on and insha Allah allows me from
that day I treat it like a fat Salah I
treat it like a fat Salah I have to do
it that's what I wanted to say guys may
Allah protect us inshallah be very very
careful and share this with your friends
and family so they are aware and do your
car Allah has told you something that
says take it before it's late and you
get inflicted and then you start crying
about it till next time
Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center if you donate to
build this Masjid Allah will be trying
to build a house for you in Jannah with
bricks of gold and silver every person
who prays in this Masjid every child
that memorized the Quran you will
inshallah share in that reward donate
now guys and do not delay
foreign